russia's invasion of ukraine has alarmed
countries across eastern europe with
fears they could be dragged into the
conflict as well latvia's capital is
less than a thousand kilometers from
both moscow and kiev it's been a full
member of nato since 2004 but the
invasion has shaken the population there
it sent millions in military aid to
ukraine and has called for western
allies to send fighter jets well joining
us now on the newshour is egales levitz
who's the president of latvia and he's
joining us from the world economic
summit in davos switzerland thank you
very much mr president for being with us
on al jazeera uh you live in a dangerous
neighborhood like ukraine the baltic
states including latvia were part of the
soviet union let me ask you first how
vulnerable
are you feeling today and how do you
assess your current relationship with
nato
and russia
yes
yeah thank you very much we are member
state of nato member state of european
union and
nato is the strongest military defense
alliance in the world
and therefore an attack to one member
state of nato means automatically attack
to all other member states and this is
solidarity of of nato and therefore we
are
secure
but we should strengthen nato as a as
our organization especially
nato
nato's eastern
flank and therefore
we will decide on that in end of june in
madrid by the next nato summit right
there seems to be resounding support at
davos to stand together at russia but
they have been splits within uh nato and
the eu also about the way forward let's
start with what's happening within nato
right now finland and sweden want to
join the alliance but turkey as you know
is opposed and there's a meeting in
ankara later today between the finn
swedes and turks can we expect a
breakthrough on that and do you think
president erdogan's concerns
about sweden and finland joining nato
are legitimate
nato is alliance of 30 member states and
all member states
are strengthened
through the membership in the alliance
including turkey and we want to
strengthen alliance more through
two new member states sweden and finland
it is also in in the interest of turkey
in the interest of all nato member
states and therefore i am sure that
turkey and finland
and
sweden
will
solve the problems which they have and
at the end uh finland and sweden will
join nato and soon
so you're hopeful about a breakthrough
but but they are divisions too mr
president within the european union
hungary is blocking a six package of
sanctions against russia that includes a
russian oil ban
and i know your prime minister will be
attending a summit of eu leaders on this
can president obama be convinced how
would you convince him that this is the
way forward
we have already agreed five packages
including of course hungary has also
agreed with five packages of course uh
now there are negotiations about the
sixth package and uh i am sure that we
will come to result because all member
states of european union has their own
uh
their own views on that but we have a
common goal
the common goal is to sanction russia
in order to
keep peace in europe because the
sanctions is an instrument to
keep peace to get peace in europe a
common goal you say mr president but
these splits
perhaps are a signal that the unity that
we saw at the start of this crisis on
ukraine
and the unity that we've seen in the
last few months is a shaky one isn't it
the european union
is
unique i would say because this is a
completely new situation where we are
now
and uh
it is a
intended unintended side effect of
putin's politics that
we have now such a unity in the european
union and in nato in the western world
as a whole
and i would say that in order to
to stabilize this unity and to go
forward we need discussions and now it
is time to
for discussions in order to get the
results and i am sure that we will get
results right now with the threat of a
global food crisis the european union
the world food program and the u.n have
been trying to get uh trapped grain out
of ukraine and lithuania is pushing for
a naval coalition
of the willing to protect sea lanes in
the black sea so that ukraine remain uh
ukraine's remaining ports can export
this grain
do you will your country be part of that
group
we are thinking about that
but of course we should do as european
union and also as international
community
to avoid
such a food crisis
because it would be a
new
global crisis the food crisis and we
should do all possible what is in our
hands to avoid that oh everything
possible some in in uh european capitals
have been suggesting mine clearing and
nato convoys for cargo ships
it's an idea that as an early stage
would you support nato being involved in
this that could pose
a a risky situation
i cannot exclude any possibility we
should
look uh
on each
possibility on on each scenario and then
that to choose the best one
mr president thank you very much for
talking to us here on al jazeera giles
levitz is latvia's president joining us
there from the world economics forum in
davao switzerland thank you very much
for your time
[Music]
thank you